le conseil général de la réunion vous
présente lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais
depuis sa création la télévision a
évolué de manière fulgurante aussi bien
techniquement que par ses contenus le
mode de transmission aussi à muter et
retient puis satellite internet et tnt
cela fait maintenant plusieurs
générations que la télévision fait
pleinement partie de notre quotidien
dans la quasi totalité des foyers ces
contenus ont énormément d'impact sur
notre société
mais la multitude de chaînes et la
diversité des programmes reflète elle
vraiment la diversité de notre culture
et de notre société
on en parle maintenant d'un lien social
la majorité des foyers réunionnais
regarde la télé pour profiter de leurs
programmes favoris les informations et
les divertissements
il y a à peine 20 ans les réunionnais ne
pouvait profiter que de trois chaînes
dans des créneaux horaires assez
restreint puis il ya eu l'arrivée des
antennes satellites avec des services
proposant des dizaines de chaînes
provoquant même l'embarras du choix
dans ces deux cas nous regardions nos
programmes de la même façon très souvent
aux heures imposées et sur un poste de
télévision
internet est en train de changer nos
habitudes puisque maintenant en plus des
grilles de programmes traditionnels
la plupart des chaînes offre la
possibilité de regarder ses émissions en
allant sur internet
cette technologie permet aux
téléspectateurs de choisir ce qu'ils
souhaitent visionner et au moment où il
le souhaite
ce service pratique et moderne a
interpellé la présidente du conseil
général
elle a rapidement pris l'initiative de
créer une web tv pour que les
réunionnais puissent entre autres
s'informer à tout moment des dispositifs
qui leur sont offerts par le conseil
général dans la continuité de cette web
tv
le département a décidé de proposer une
chaîne avec des contenus choisi dans
l'intérêt des réunionnais l'idée étant
de respecter la ligne de conduite et le
devoir du conseil général à savoir
apporter des services et des solutions à
tous les réunionnais alors 9 7 4 télé à
la vocation d'être au service des
réunionnais d'abord et avant tout c'est
la télé du conseil général mais c'est
surtout la télé dernière ag vous donne
un exemple très concret vous avez dans
vos entre dans votre entourage une
personne qui est malentendante voulez
communiquer avec elle il faut apprendre
le langage des signes apprend le langage
des signes ça nécessite de se déplacer
d'aller dans une réunion en vis-à-vis
avec un professeur balla professeurs y
sera dans la télévision et vous pourrez
apprendre le langage des signes
gratuitement sans vous déplacer sans
avoir à prendre votre voiture simplement
vous associant d'autres devant votre
télévision ça va peut-être concerner 50
100 200 réunionnais mais au moins 100
objectifs financiers jusqu'à pas
publicité dans notre 7,4 télé vous aurez
la capacité de mieux communiquer avec
une place ou malentendantes tout en
découvrant est un moyen une façon de
communiquer qui est vraiment au service
de la plus grande plage
et telle réunion le concept de base de
nos sept cas télé c'est d'être dans
l'esprit du web
l'esprit des pages facebook l'esprit de
dailymotion ou youtube
c'est faire de petites émissions de
petit format 3 minutes six minutes mais
faire en sorte que vous veniez piocher
dans les contenus dans la grille
programme de cette catelli et que vous
découvriez l'émission qui est diffusée
au moment où vous allumez votre télé et
vous y soyez accroché que pendant trois
quatre cinq six minutes vous intéressiez
à une histoire à un service du conseil
général à un portrait de réunionnais
formidable et peut-être encore mieux à
un contenu audiovisuel qui aurait été
produit par vous grâce à votre
smartphone grâce à votre appareil photo
qui fait la vidéo grâce à une petite
application sur votre tablette
et vous allez vous en voyez un contenu
de la valade du week-end dernier où de
la jolie fleur qui a poussé dans le
jardin de belle-maman
et vous allez nous raconter vos si votre
petite histoire et en la diffusant à
sion à cette cape et 9,7 capter laisser
la télé des réunionnais et cndd et les
participative à l'image du savoir vivre
ensemble
cette chaîne de télévision permet aux
réunionnais de continuer de partager
d'échanger avec plus de facilité à
travers divers programmes nous pourrons
encore mieux nous connaître et faire
perdurer ce qui caractérise notre île le
mélange des cultures des gt rugy minois
de télé sur le site internet du conseil
général
parce qu'au conseil général nous faisons
beaucoup de choses et que l'information
vers les publics qui ont droit à des
prestations ou également à des
subventions puisse être la plus large
possible et ce site est aujourd'hui
largement fréquenté par les réunionnais
qu'ils peuvent avoir en ligne
directement toutes les réponses aux
questions qui peuvent se poser c'est est
un site d'information et aujourd'hui
nous allons plus loin nous créons
véritablement une télé 97,4 mais pas
seulement ouvert au conseil général et
sur nos dispositifs mais à toutes les
associations à tous ceux qui veulent
travailler aux sociétés de production
pour faire passer leurs messages
communiqués s'ouvrir et ouvrait à
l'information
une communication à l'ensemble des
réunionnais ça sera en ligne sur the hop
également et j'espère que cette télé
97,4 sera la mieux partagée pour le site
n'hésitez pas si vous avez un reportage
là à petit flip même
et à la vie familiale et bien fait le
passé sur ce site là pour le partager
avec les plus grands noms avec cette
chaîne de télévision le département
continue de prouver qu'il est dans l'air
du temps ne 7,4 et v n'a qu'une ambition
c'est rendre service et apporter des
solutions à tous les réunionnais
quel que soit le milieu social ou
culturel sans aucun intérêt financier
elle consacre l'intégralité de ses
programmes à la réunion et ses habitants
le conseil général de la réunion vous a
présenté lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais